let's talk about the crew a very funny
show and a great idea
because it's set in the world of nascar
and um it really which is
a hugely popular part of
america you know and americana and
um so it seemed to me like it was a good
decision to set it there
and your character it feels like this
gives you an impression to kind of
try different things you know what i
mean like you've been you've been
working a couple of impressions
in there every now and then oh yeah
uh this is i'm not great at impressions
but
one of my uh co-workers did a uh
so i had to pull out the de niro
impression right away
because just just the face yeah it was
just one of those
it's not good no um yeah i'm not good at
impressions i don't have do you have
impressions
i don't do i mean i do cartoony
impressions
over the years of certain people like
for years i would do schwarzenegger
years and years ago
and then i realized it's basically uh a
dictator ranting
um and it sounds like he has sausage in
his mouth
but did you do any of your friends
because i know you and ray romano were
tight
and everybody hurray
come on you know that was always that
one then everybody started doing race so
i went away from that uh-huh
i had a little bit of a rocky for a
while rocky balboa
the the rocky mountain which everybody
had just had my own you know
it was all that stuff right but what i
like is i have a mickey with you
yeah mickey no trainer do mick no
everyone does rocky no one does mickey
yeah
let me try to do a mickey okay
are you you flying bombs into your feet
[Laughter]
you have to yeah between him and
stallone you you need subtitles to know
what's going on that's
very good
that's very good the thing i don't i
don't do a ray romano impression but the
thing i've noticed about him is that for
a guy who's had so much
success in his life it hasn't changed
him at all and he's just and he's always
just kind of
ah yeah yeah and and
i don't know uh and every time i see him
i'm like rice good to see you it's so
good
ah it's a sunny day i could rain soon
that's like i don't know yeah
yeah is personified yeah he's he's
amazing
you can't you can't you you won't get to
talk very much uh into a conversation
you'll get deep into it without him
bringing up a skin tag
or uh just something bad in his life
that's gone
alright yeah you're like all right well
things are good right yeah you're doing
it right
yeah i am but come on you know it's like
how many years could i have left uh
so you play uh in in the crew you're the
the crew chief
of this nascar racing team so uh
and and and what's again what's nice is
it's a good ensemble piece
because it's it works into the show very
nicely that there's a bunch of people
you have to work with
and so you get these great characters
involved and i would imagine also
uh you get you get to have some real
nascar personalities come in
without a doubt yeah we've had ryan
blaney and uh cole custer and these guys
are great they're great actors too which
which annoyed me honestly they were very
funny when they came on the set
uh that's the one of the benefits of
being having nascar behind you you know
so you're not doing
smash car you know where you're kind of
making up this world
they give you everything they give you
cars we've had the drivers and
and all that but uh the key to it is man
is the cast of this one for me
because i mean i've done domestic
comedies before and this is a workplace
comedy which is different for me
but the ball man you can dish the ball
to them and they're just fantastic
they're just so great they're young
good funny they they really pissed me
off in a way because they are
so good like i thought i'd be the old
guy kind of giving them the tips of a
sitcom how a sitcom works and all that
stuff they're they're really they're
much better than i ever was so it's
it's it's a pleasure to share this i can
relate to that i get really irritated
when
uh really good-looking athletes are also
very funny yes and i'm like blake
griffin you don't need
this yes you're so good
in one area of your life and then you do
this and i'm like oh
oh you're really quick and funny yeah
this is all i ever had
a little bit of and you know what i mean
i can't
dabble in what you're doing it's
irritating well we have a clip here
we have a clip here from the crew and uh
anything we need to do to set this up
i don't i'm not sure we need anything
for it no i don't think i
know not during covid if we don't do
setups during covid
no they were taken away
[Laughter]
that's the thing i want when kovit's
over and we all get vaccinated i want my
setups
i want setups to come back
all right let's take a look at this clip
from the crew all right here you
go and our waitress apologizes ryan
blaney
grabbed your wings off the car before
she picked them up what
son of a [ __ ] ryan blamey
you just took me off i think so that's a
weird way to lick your fingers
hey what are you doing we figured you
had enough wings
we just sat down no we mean like in life
oh hey austin i didn't see you there why
don't you hop up on blinny's shoulders
and come in as one person
i'm 5'8 that's average height if you
stand in your helmet yar
that helmet won the daytona 500. i just
want to have one meal without you
bringing that up man
so they funny yeah and they have a sense
of humor about themselves too
they do they're really good uh and and
one quick question you had i heard an
audience laughing so that was
probably shot just pre-coveted are you
able to shoot
now and and how do you how do you work
it out we shot seven episodes
with a live audience which was fire it
was great and then we had
three we were able to come back and
finish the three
without an audience so that was brutal
because of the energy you don't
you know you you got to keep it up and
you don't realize how much you fall off
without that
live audience so kevin you're talking to
a guy who built his career
on pity laughs and so
i i need them very badly